hello everybody
what happened Asia made the move as as
you know guys if you watch the
yesterday's video we were talking
um there was a lot of liquidations at 29
100.
and we found Abby peculiar that Bitcoin
went to 29 250 and then bound from there
and went to 29 500 and at this moment is
what I filmed the video and I said that
this is the most likely a room for
liquidity
to make people open more longs
so the liquidation and the stop losses
are 29 100 can increase so when they
come back down they can be more
effective and hit more liquidations and
more stop losses
and Asia did it exactly at the opening
of the talk of the Hong Kong session
you can see how Asia just went down also
they could understand that this is um a
stophunt
okay you can see that this would be
the support Zone that the retail Trader
would think it is but we were already
looking at 29 100 and yes you can see
very clearly how we had the retail
support Zone a lot of Liquidations in
high block are 29 100 the logic telling
us that they were gonna bring price back
down a stop hunt
and return reversal okay and that's what
basically happened during the ancient
session but if we look at the chart
again we can see some interesting things
going on here okay let me remove these
things
okay we showed the stophunt
reversal in this in session and it's
quite interesting
that Asia pumped okay because if you
guys follow me on Twitter you probably
have seen my tweets many many times
saying that I don't trust ACM pumps why
because they tend to get retraced
usually in the next New York session or
if not in the next Asian session and
there is a pattern here
let me show you so let me Mark this in
session that's from
um 1am UTC time to eight
okay
let's mark it there and then we have the
London session
which is from eight until America until
two the guys in the course know why
and the New York session
sorry that's not what I wanted to do and
the New Year session from two
to nine okay
so this is a pattern that we can see
pretty often let me put it to the 30
minutes time frame so we can see it more
clearly
okay that's eight
okay yeah that's that's good like this
now
Asia pumped okay what can we expect in
the London session and in the New York
session well there is a pattern here
that it's Asia pumps
London halts and then if London holds
we can expect New York to retrace okay
that pump in any sensation
so we would expect something like this
we still have about three hours in the
London session okay but if the London
season closes
around the opening price the opening
price is around 29
777 Okay so
I don't care that London did this pump
over here
the only thing that I care is that it
closes around this level okay if
increase around this level we can for
example see at right at the start of the
New York session a push and a retrace
okay so that's what I'm looking at now
I'm only gonna look for the scalps if I
see an opportunity and if I don't see
any opportunity I'm not gonna worry
because in the New York season there is
always a lot more of volatility
and if London ends up holding the range
then I'm gonna look for this move in the
New York session of course they can just
do this away but
will probably see a bit of a false move
right at the start of a new year session
maybe a push up and then a retrace but
there is another another plane here what
about this doesn't happen okay
the middle of this this doesn't happen
London keeps keeps pumping okay closes
the closes the session around these
levels that's a pump okay so then the
New York retrace my opinion will be
invalidated that one I won't be looking
at that and then I will be looking to
the next Zone to the upside that would
be
this liquidity pool over here
you can see that's a big imbalance
okay
and that would be the next Target to the
website all the way until
thirty thousand three hundred dollars so
that's pretty much everything that I'm
looking at in today's chart
um Asia in a summary in a nutshell
Asia pumped now if London holds and
closes around 29 800 then I would
probably expect New York to retrace
and if London closed the decision with a
pump
then I want to I will not be looking for
a drop in the New York session and I'll
probably be looking for this area to get
hit
so that's pretty much everything that I
wanted to say today if you liked the
video please show some support and I
mean we've already reached 1 000
subscribers how I don't know guys you're
crazy have a nice day and I'll see you
soon